okay today on the bonus show we are
going to talk about my fourth of July
break as well as Pat's fourth of July
break and I had such a great experience
back in my old neighborhood in Brooklyn
New York
as many of you know from August 2013 to
June 2015 the David Pakman show
broadcast from New York City I lived in
Brooklyn I was back in New York City for
a wedding weekend and I went back to my
old spots in Brooklyn this includes the
great cocktail bar clover club Club it
includes all sorts of different places I
was back in my stomping grounds very
nostalgic it was an incredibly nostalgic
weekend and I walk into the great Smith
Street bagels formerly known as mocha
bagels on Smith Street in Brooklyn and
I'm there with my girlfriend and I order
my Agins Swiss on an everything bagel
lightly toasted as I often do and I get
to the front of the line and I see that
Eddie is still running the cash register
at Smith Street bagels the place has
been renovated they've got a hipster
espresso bar they've got all sorts of
new stuff but it's still Eddie he
immediately recognizes me and says Dave
where have you been
and I have a back story with Eddie
because once I was I leave reviews on
Yelp so I remember what places I like if
I'm in the neighborhood whatever and I
left a review that was I will admit
mediocre because of a bad experience I
had my first time at the former loot
former mocha bagels and Eddie read the
review
he found it found out who is this David
Pakman he found out about the show and
next time I went in he recognized me and
he said I know about your review I was
really upset to hear about your
experience my customers are like family
he gave me some free black and white
cookies and ever since you know I would
go in there and talk to Eddie I had been
gone for almost three years from
Brooklyn and he immediately recognized
me he said he's still following the show
that the team at Smith Street bagels
they support what we're doing and it was
great and it was a great instance of
community
and I don't know what else to call it
friendship and inspiration so if you're
ever in Brooklyn go visit Eddie at Smith
Street bagels tell him that you heard
about it on the David Pakman show and
he's got great bagels and don't miss the
black and white cookies please yeah very
heartwarming story he must have known
that you moved to Boston though right if
he's a regular viewer of the show he was
aware that I was no longer in New York
City I don't know
he immediately parodied and satirized
the stereotypical Boston accent so he
seemed to have somewhat of an inkling of
what was going on but yes go see Eddie
Smith street bagels shout out to him and
both of us will talk more about our
vacations in proper terms on the bonus
show today w w join pakman.com
patreon.com slash david pakman show